bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
va bien les syndics la belle angie
meeting et qu'il y ait à une société
hyper innovantes france est ce que tu
peux m'expliquer de quoi ça partout bien
sûr
alors on a dit le swing pareil sur des
objets connectés donc
mighty pim atypique à un objet
permettant de garder contact avec tout
ce qui compte à nos yeux avec celui ci
par exemple est plutôt dédié à la maison
voyez c'est un objet élégant
en bois fait à la main mais une france
avec du bois auvergnats donc ça on est
purement les dinos vergne et qui permet
de garder le contact donc avec votre
maison trop loin on garde le contact en
fait un détecteur de présence on a les
capteurs de température d'hygrométrie
mon cas ce week-end au qatar de danser
les petits trous qu'on a sur lequel
exactement une et quatre heures sur
l'intérieur est bon
pour que ça puisse communiquer on
détecte les alarmes incendie et coupures
de courant donc l'accord donc on a deux
caps usage particulier le cas des usages
numéro un c'est par exemple résidence
secondaire ou une maison de famille où
c'est toujours un peu pénible d'arrivée
le vendredi soir dans sa maison de
famille de se rendre compte que je veux
dire à casser une semaine avant et qui
fait 3 degré qu'on a perdu tout sens à
vos congés elle est au frigo
donc ça permet de remédier à ces soucis
dans les capteurs pouces qu'électricité
tommy capteur de cooper courant pour
s'achever à comprendre pourquoi ces
tremblements que l'on peut le brancher
donc si à toulouse un secteur
relativement sûr secteurs générateurs si
tu n'as pas de secteur pouvait le mettre
dans un autre endroit tout simplement
équipé de deux batteries lr4 avec ses
deux batteries et donc grâce à réseau
cifog on peut encore parler tout à
l'heure on la grâce au réseau cyclable
c'est très peu énergivore avec de nerfs
4 contient quasiment
donc tu le reçoit en fait il est hyper
autonome et très accessible dans quoi
ils accessibles c'est que depuis leur
soif comment sur internet et on reçoit
on appuie sur ce petit bouton répondait
à oreille frêche le code qui va être sur
le
les mighty en installe sur son salon
donc sur la table de son salon sur un
meuble et il en fonction des goûts en
huit mois ils partagent l'avantagent
donc si quoi que c'est un réseau dédié
des billes pas besoin de wii fit pas
besoin de 3g pas besoin de quatre j'ai
besoin de rien envie de toi besoin de
rien j'ai pensé en venant c'est xavier
ruiz et dans le doubs le double avantage
qu'ici part excessive soit csfr possible
utilisation
mais pour une personne âgée touchée ces
autonomes accessible très facile
d'utilisation et
sa solution vraiment tous les problèmes
du quotidien dont on est inquiet sur
tout ce qui a de la valeur à nos yeux
donc pas et qui fit donc encore toit en
bois
on a développé un aussi également en
plastique dédié pour les caves les
parkings et éventuellement même les
bateaux voilà qu'à des usages sur le
bateau et
et aussi pour du smart building pour la
gestion des salles de réunion comme un
capteur de présence on est capable de
gérer le
le prêt de voir s'il ya des gens au nom
dans les salles dernière dernière chose
sur haïti pile avantage c'est que
certifié ce produit pour le moment
en europe on est certifié aussi pour la
norme fc c'est donc la mairie
d'accord et donc on lance un kickstarter
ceux qui voudraient nous suivre faudra
suivre le lien sur my tipi
twitter je vais mettre dans la
description d'accord donc mighty pie ix
et viau signe sur twitter pour les
vainqueurs qui seront vraiment les plus
intéressés on va produire une petite
série de mighty pikine starter dédié
vous attendez vous êtes les bienvenus
génial alors l'idée je viens d'où sur ce
produit de créer c'est quoi l'on vit
c'est quoi la motivation qui donne envie
de bosser sur ce projet le projet c'est
qu'on est on
vraiment dédié aux objets connectés on
veut quelque chose de très simple très
facile à utiliser
pas spécialement pour les geeks parce
que ces gens allaient faire compliqué
quand d'autres sont accessibles pour
tout le monde donc l'idée c'était simple
fiable beau et robuste et tu penses
qu'il manquait quelque chose
il manquait quelque chose parce que tout
simplement aujourd'hui
en parler de deux points importants qui
sont l'accessibilité nos preuves et
autonomie l'autonomie c'est toujours
difficile de brancher des choses on peut
pas les bronches et celui ci par exemple
un appartement de prise dans une case
dans un parking
c'est facile d'avoir ou même dans un
cellier je vais garder ton des bonnes
bouteilles de vin
au moins tu peux tu veux que le guet et
puis et puis surtout l'autonomie d'avoir
une autonomie de 8 mois c'est juste
exceptionnel et
sans changer les piles d'avril juste à
changer des vies de ce monde sait faire
donc
on voulait vraiment de solutionner ça en
donnant
l'accès en gros de l'objet connecter à
n'importe qui un objet design encore une
fois à made in france c'est pas quelque
chose qui est fabriqué en chine c'est
quoi le bras cassés du marronnier ça
c'est dû être s'est fait par un ébéniste
à clermont d'accord voilà donc cette
assemblée par nous qui ferait de toute
l'électronique et 8 à 88 est fait par
nous vous vous êtes vous êtes basé
notamment à clermont-ferrand
donc elle est cool alors qu'à mon tour
d'être bloqués
ok et alors du coup je me posais la
question est-ce qu'à une grosse
communauté
de start up innovantes à clermont
ferrand ça commence il ya un incubateur
qui a été créé qui s'appelle de bivouac
sur pierre mongin qui est labellisé
french tech
autour de la mobilité avec pas mal de
partenaires comme certains grands
groupes comme joueur limagrain
on passe à eux
que qui supporte les
hartock une soirée cuvée la barre
du coup on a
un an d'existence aujourd'hui
on a été créé et social dans ce biberach
ben voilà
on est très heureux d'y être maintenant
on espère voler de nos propres ailes
assez vite je vous souhaite donc double
intérêt cette mise sur le marché de ce
premier produit qu'on appelle d'autres
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a avec quatre
autres produits qui seront bientôt aussi
vente
au tournage et aux localisations da
surveillance en général et du monitoring
d'activité
ok cool bon bah écoute
soit fabien beaucoup de réussite merci
ça marche ça marche bien que vous ayez
beaucoup de bakker et quelques jets
cartonne c'est beaucoup je vous invite
vous à me laisser des commentaires et à
me dire ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que des produits comme celui ci
pourrait vous intéresser est ce que vous
êtes sensibles effectivement toute cette
problématique
marquis moi tout ça en commentaire on
reste bien évidemment connectez vous
êtes année c'est des jolies pousse à
vous abonner et on va parler énormément
d'entreprises françaises innovantes donc
la sécurité parce qu'il ya des choses
passionnantes qui arrive à bientôt
[Musique]